and we've created extended ivr so we're
creating a program
that will allow students to take student
loans to attend make school
at relatively low interest rates
[Music]
jeremy rossman welcome to 20 minute
leaders i'm so happy you're here
hi michael how's it going good how are
you nsf
hanging in there we just saw each other
a couple of months ago at make school
and everything was normal little did we
know
little tiny things are picking up all
right
who are you i am one of the founders of
make school
make school is a new college in san
francisco formally operating out of a
campus with
dorms faculty clubs all the normal a
full university a full college
an accredited college that's right so
you get a bachelor's we have one major
it's an applied computer science major
we are currently operating fully online
um and
uh um you know started
offline uh and operated as such for many
years and we'll see what the future
holds for us but
we're taking the approach of being ready
for whatever eventuality so if we have
to teach online we'll continue teaching
online if we teach offline we'll
continue teaching offline
we're going to crush it either way is is
the goal and
you know nothing is ever perfect but in
this world you have to adapt quickly and
really try your hardest to
uh to kind of rise up to the challenge
what we're seeing
is a lot of schools are having a lot of
challenges adapting to this new reality
and i i'm not going to pretend that it's
easy for us
but i think we're really fortunate that
we our faculty are mostly
former engineers who have a lot of
experience
if not with full remote work which some
of them do with at least substantial
work from home
flexibility they know tools technology
systems communication frameworks that
allow them
to really do a better job of remote
instruction than a faculty member who
might be going online for the first time
and so by basically drawing inspiration
from industry best practices and using
our faculty as the
kind of shining light um you know things
are things are hanging in there and
student satisfaction on the on the
online courses is actually
uh we have we have something like a
third of students that say the school is
better now that it's online which we'll
see how long that
yeah yeah we're still only a few weeks
in but that was a really surprising
thing
um and the majority of students you know
say it's better or as good as it was so
fingers crossed that we can keep that up
but we're really proud of that
so jeremy make school is not a regular
university it is one of the most unique
universities in the world
because you know every most universities
in the world you pay to go to them and
you pay
sometimes a lot of money you know the
student loan debt in the us
is is in is one of the biggest debts i
think in the us
and billion dollars yeah crazy and make
school
you actually they come and study for
free under the premise that when they
get a job not if but when they get an
engineering position
then then they contribute back to make
school and you know when we did tldr i
remember my favorite sentence was that
he told me was
you know when we wake up every morning
and come to work we know that we don't
get paid until our students get paid
and that that a combined incentive
in that win-win situation tell me about
it it's beautiful
well so funny you should mention that
some things have changed on that front
in the past couple of months
um not in uh at all in the core mission
but in the implementation of the mission
so
it's been it's been really interesting
to see how that's evolved um
so the core of the may school model
which is not changing at all
is when students graduate if they don't
have a job they don't have to pay
um and the amount that they have to pay
is
uh is is proportional to their salaries
such that they're not stuck with a debt
burden with montgomery
and afford and that sort of thing the
model that we've been using for many
years is called an income share model we
were one of the first schools to use
that in 2014
and students basically pay a flat
percentage of their pre-tax salary
uh and there's a threshold below which
if they're not making up to that amount
they don't have to pay we have a portion
of the funding that comes through living
expenses if you're not making more than
40k you didn't have to pay that if
for the portion that goes for tuition if
you're not making more than 60k you
didn't have to pay that
now you might have heard that a
pandemic has ravaged the world yep a
little bit
and at the moment the funding to make
the next round of income share
agreements actually is on hold
so this model that makes school has been
doing for six years now
wow we have to rapidly think through
okay how do you keep the mission
intact yeah the incentive alignment
intact so how do you make it painful for
the school
when the student isn't successful and so
we started doing a tremendous amount of
research as to
what what now yeah we've come up with
something what is this episode gonna
hear uh i think in about
three weeks three four weeks okay
perfect then it'll be it'll be kosher to
announce by then
um so we're designing this program
called eivr
so isa if we can get the funding for it
we'll still exist but right now that's
kind of rocky to be perfectly honest
with you four weeks from now we'll see
what the reality ended up being
okay plan a is this new program that
we're introducing called eibr
eibr stands for expanded income based
repayment
why that name when students go for
student loans
to pay for college there's a portion of
the student loans
called direct loans that actually come
with
default protections built in where if
you don't have a job you don't have to
pay
okay these are loans that are eligible
for what's called an ibr repayment plan
which caps your monthly payments at 10
of your discretionary income
meaning that students who choose that
payment plan at lower salaries
can have their monthly payments
significantly reduced or if they have no
job they pay zero
okay now the problem is when you hear
about student loans being this big evil
thing which
they basically are what students
typically are struggling with is not the
tranche
that they took in direct loans which for
many students caps out at around thirty
thousand dollars
but that's if you take it over multiple
years in a row
it's the part that is substantially
greater usually that they took out in
private loans or
other types of federal loans that don't
have that protection yeah so for most
students
a a especially for a program that is a
four-year program
that is a full bachelor's program a
program that um maybe is on the more
expensive side
most of your student debt will usually
be in a form that is not protected by
ibr
wow so what we've done is we've modeled
after
those ibr protections and we've created
extended ivr
so we're creating a program that will
allow students to take student loans
to attend make school at relatively low
interest rates
so actually on average and this is going
to be interesting
in almost every case students will pay
back a lot less than under isa
because under the isa plan you are
paying a fixed percentage of your
salaries
and students are getting salaries from
make school that are much higher than we
initially modeled
we had models getting yeah we have
students out there
making net effective comp 140 to 180
wow at 19 to 21 years old and those
students are not the average but there's
enough of them that they're looking at
us going wait a second what do you mean
twenty percent of that number
you know it sounded great when they were
enrolling yeah
twenty percent of my salary maybe one
day i'll make 100k
now they make 150 and they're going wait
a second that's a huge number so
we we're working on eibr so the way that
it's going to work
is make school will pay
your student loans for you if you fall
below certain
salary thresholds and if you don't have
a job we'll pay them all for you
wow so so we take the protection that
the government has designed for the
direct loans and we expand it to all of
your government or
private loans depending on what you
choose to take wow which has
three effects one incentive alignment is
still there
right if we we we get paid until we
don't because
if you don't have a job then we have to
pay for you right so it's it's a form of
like refund policy essentially right
every month every month that you can't
afford those loans we will we have to
pitch in and make the payments for you
also means you'll never accrue interest
on those loans you won't be in default
on those loans make schools on the hook
not you right
the second thing it achieves is um a
more equitable
distribution of payments for students
that are in our typical outcome bands
so that means students who are earning
typical engineer salaries will be paying
less for make school
sometimes depending on how much they
take out to the tune of 50k or more or
less
than they would under under the current
plan
and the third thing that it achieves is
on a on a cohort basis the average paid
back
is is uh is quite a bit less so
when you look at the average case the
individual typical case
payback is less and then when you look
at uh
the school we are incentivized uh just
as much as we were
and so that is the default plan at the
moment now there's a chance that by the
time this episode
airs isa funding is back in the picture
as you might know with the markets
um uncertain as they are sure and the
lending markets in particular
contracting
um the funders for isa right now said
pause don't promise that to students yet
we need to rework what the deal is
but we've been able to create this eibr
thing which is not announced as of today
but by the time this episode airs will
be announced
and we're going to have these full
tables that show for every income
bracket
how much you would have had to pay under
the old plan
and how much you have to pay under this
one and basically uh
it's it's it's better in in most cases
and regardless we cap your your payments
at a certain percent of your income so
you never have a
debt payment you can't afford it wow no
jeremy i have such a privilege both
speaking to somebody who founded a
university i can't even believe i'm
saying this founded a university
admittedly a college because we don't
have master's programs okay
you know i'm from israel i don't know
the difference college university
whatever
sony you funded a car university
soon but not soon enough you know i
remember i remember when you announced
that you got the accreditation to do the
applied computer science degree
unbelievable and i came to san francisco
myself and i saw the class in session
and i saw how all of you are working and
you were showing me how you're doing
construction on these different areas
just unbelievable how did you i mean i
remember five years ago you came as a
sponsor
to hack gen y the hackathon yes and
you're you were the
you were one of the keynote speakers yes
you were talking about make school the
summer program
how did this all even start and get to
become a college
so between 2012 and 2014 make school was
up to two things
we were running a summer program for
high school and college students
who felt like they wanted to develop
practical
computer science software engineering
skills and build a portfolio that they
could use
high school students would often
leverage what they built in the summer
to make their college apps look shinier
and many college students use what they
built in the summer as an entryway into
getting awesome internships
so early on we started having awesome
outcomes students even at universities
as prestigious as mit and uc berkeley
would be willing to be quoted
saying the reason that i got my
internship at facebook or at square
was thanks to the make school summer
academy wow that good thing that we were
doing
was we were taking repackaging the
summer program curriculum and we were
selling it to universities
so we actually had as a largest customer
at the time carnegie mellon
really yeah we helped many universities
either in front of the scenes or behind
the scenes introduce some of their first
ever app development courses
in 2014 we realized that if we were
super popular as of course embedded at
other universities
and we were super popular with college
students on summer break
then why supplement the system by
plugging gaps for other schools
let's build our own school so we stopped
selling curriculum
universities and we launched our own
pilot of what turned into the college
wow 2014 that had 11 students and 2015
it had 20-something students um and
today
there's like 107 something students in
the program
with another 150 to 200 new students
expected next fall
we operated as an alternative to college
you don't have to go to college you come
to make pool
from 2014 to 2018 in 2018 we got our
accreditation but kept the program
length compressed
so make school you actually get a
four-year applied computer science
bachelor's degree that is
regionally accredited which is the top
standard of accreditation
out in the west coast um and you get
that four-year degree
in two to two and a half years depending
on what course those you take
so we we switch from having a two-year
non-degree program to a two-year degree
program
we uh you know if you don't have a job
you don't have to pay that is
still true and we're really proud to say
like
pandemic you know times are creating
some job market pressure
right um tens of millions of americans
are out of a job yeah
i'm not gonna sit here and tell you that
it's likely that we are unaffected but
i will say so far we've only had one
student that we know of who had their
internship cancelled
and in the past six weeks apple pandora
zendesk and other big companies have
made offers to our students wow
honestly good fingers crossed um
you know is that you know it all depends
on how the situation evolves and so on
and so forth i don't want to be
insensitive to that but
um we have a huge focus on taking
best practices for cs theory teaching cs
theory in a project-based way
combining that with concentrations
either mobile development web
development data science
that are taught fully project-based with
the latest and greatest tools and having
students build up portfolio items in
every single class so every single class
results in some sort of artifacts you
can put in your portfolio and in a time
of crisis and uncertainty you kind of
want to be certain the person you're
going to hire knows how to do the work
and make school students all have
portfolios that kind of show you rather
than tell you you know i don't have to
give
an employer a gpa because i can just say
look at my students github right
and that's been really really good for
our outcomes uh
in terms of employment and yeah that's
kind of the high level of the story
going from a summer program to a
curriculum vendor to an alternative to
college to a college college
i'm all in the short span of eight years
so jeremy where did you go to school
remind me
you know the answer to that question i
went to mit okay
and i started off with lofty aspirations
of majoring in computer science
to be honest i basically
you know i guess the world has gone
remote it's okay to use internet
language in real
world now because what's the real world
except for online i noped out of there
real quick um when it came to computer
science courses i remember going to my
first ever cs class lecture
and being like not really happening
i was fortunate to have access to
amazing project-based progressive
computer science education in high
school
when i got to mit i was expecting more
of the same and the lecture-based
100 students in the same class kind of
situation i instantly disengaged that
did not fit my learning style i just
could not do it
and i immediately started um teaming up
with friends to make iphone apps because
the app store was new back then it was
relatively new
so what happened was i i finished my
sophomore year and i'm like wait a
second
i've learned a lot more about product
development
industry best practices and cs
from teaming up with friends and
designing coding and launching
an iphone game sure then i have from any
formal cs class which i basically
took one of and then was like no i
actually switched to being a media
studies major briefly at mit before
dropping really
so by the time i started make school
the whole goal was just to teach cs in
the way i wish it had been taught to me
so we created those first ever courses
they were designed for students like me
who are not good at teaching themselves
something out of a book not good at
teaching themselves something out of a
lecture
who need high touch instructional
support but if they have it can be very
high performing
one of the things that is important to
know about the world of software
engineering
is that it's full of survivorship bias
the people out there who are successful
many of them are in that five to ten
percent of people who made it through
the no support lecture-based
textbook-based type of education and
we've come to think maybe that's what it
means to be good at computer science
but that's false there are people out
there like i was i'd like to think
who are very high potential but whose
learning style is best supported by
project-based learning
and having actual experts available as
your faculty who can be your mentors to
unblock you when you get stuck
not sitting there as stages on the stage
experts in front of the room talking at
you for an hour
right and so what we did is we built a
more flipped classroom experience
project-based learning and it was so
send me a picture jeremy pay me a
picture i'm walking into the
make school classroom uh i saw it on my
own eyes but i want you to paint a
picture to whoever's watching this
because it's different
it's completely empty because we're not
all online oh until further notice
no um uh and actually we've used online
you know between
zoom zoom breakout rooms our learning
management system like i think things
are pretty buttoned down
but a lot of the time if you walk into a
random class what you see
is a bunch of students coding so they
have their ide
up and they have uh tutorial materials
up that are guiding them through some
sort of project
and then there's faculty and tas who are
roaming and and
helping individual students unblocking
them as they get uh as they get stuck
then periodically there's gonna be
recaps to do checks for understanding
and help highlight certain points
conceptual or otherwise
that the whole class needs to rely on
right and then back to project work
classes often split between assigned
projects we say hey you're going to
build this here's how
and then open projects we say you're
going to build something of your own
conception but it must satisfy these
requirements
and so students can go back and forth
between both kinds of projects we also
have the full complement of general
education now
from communication to history to
sciences and all that
which makes you know integral part of a
real degree
and as much as people might think that
that stuff is is fluff the reality is
employers tell us all the time that they
want it
they want students who've gone through
that stuff and they see our students as
being even more competitive to hire
because we haven't cut that stuff out of
the curriculum and that's been given
given us a great advantage as well
in a world full of boot camps everyone's
kind of taken the shortest path we
haven't cut
the communication the teamwork the
project management the
history the philosophy that you need to
be a well-rounded universal society and
also team member so
and i mean a lot of these workshops are
also taught by professionals
that are in the that are working at the
same time right they're not full-time
lecturers some you have people that are
coming in from the industry to support
this right so
most of the faculty are actually
full-timers where the thing they were
doing immediately before
was full-time in industry so they're a
lot of our faculty kind of do rotations
like
they'll come teach with us for like two
three years and they'll go back to
industry wonderful
also have classes that are being taught
by industry so for example
yelp taught our technical interviewing
class uh which was pretty cool
um and uh we're working
we have google is teaching a
pre-orientation program
for students this summer so before you
start your first class google is going
to run a program
uh for baseball students and then we
also are about to announce which i guess
by the time this errors will be
announced
then microsoft and lyft are doing their
first ever
on campus or i guess online at this
point
uh partnership of the kind where they're
going to be supporting
a lot of our like technical interview
prep
algorithms prep and so on and so forth
to get students ready for
um for technical internships and
apprenticeships so we're going to be
announcing a microsoft we'll have you
know yelp google microsoft and lyft in
the mix it's like actual companies
teaching content that is integrated into
the curriculum jeremy our 20 minutes
went by
way way too quickly way too fast but i'm
gonna put you on the spot
for once and i know that you can handle
it i would like you to tell me three
words
that you think best describe yourself or
if i would ask anybody in the make
school campus
how would they describe you three words
um extroverted
optimistic analytical
i like the combination of the three it
sounds okay it sounds like a good a good
idea
jeremy thank you so much thanks so much
for having me this was great
take care
you